the west bank of the river nile
home to the world's most iconic
monuments
the mighty pyramids of giza
the pyramids once housed the bodies of
the pharaohs
but though ancient egyptian civilization
lasted for nearly three thousand years
its kings only built huge tombs like
these for a few centuries
egyptologists are still trying to piece
together why the pharaoh stopped
constructing
giant pyramids for egyptologist chris
norton
the majesty of the ancient structures
makes the fact that
egyptians gave up building them all the
more incredible
10 miles south of the legendary pyramids
of giza
is sakara when we think about pyramids
we tend to think of
giza i think in the great pyramid of
khufu in particular but actually this is
where it all began
chris has come to the birthplace of
pyramid building to search for clues to
why egyptians built
giant pyramids for less than 500 years
constructed a century before the iconic
pyramids at giza
egypt's first pyramid is a 200-foot tall
mausoleum
of six huge limestone platforms
carefully engineered to spread the
weight of rock and prevent collapse
deep inside is a giant shaft
26 feet wide and 82 feet deep
at the bottom the intended final resting
place of the pharaoh jose
ultimately that's what it's all about
that's when the body of the king is
going to rest in eternity and to have
gone to all this trouble to create this
incredible monument around the body of
that person
it's pretty amazing to house his mummy
huge chunks of granite were slid down a
passage into the shaft and stacked
creating a giant sarcophagus 19 feet
long
and 11 feet high
my god these pieces are huge
wow it's amazing
but this wasn't just a tomb designed to
secure the pharaoh's physical body for
eternity
crucially for success in the afterlife
the pyramid ensured the king was
remembered by the living
completed around 2650 bc
it sparked an architectural revolution
joseph's six-tier giant wasn't just the
first pyramid
it was the world's first monumental
structure built in stone
over the next century egypt's kings
developed the concept
building monumental tombs all along the
niles west bank
including the first geometrically true
pyramid
the red pyramid and a misshapen
experiment
the bent pyramid then a dynasty of
pharaohs built the most iconic monuments
in egypt
the pyramids of giza
but just a few short centuries after the
great pyramid of khufu
rose from the desert a new era was on
the horizon
[Music]
you